thank you for joining us America we're
glad you are here Brittany is with us in
Houston hi Brittany welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi how are you better than I
deserve what's up good so are going to
get your advice on something
hi I'm 22 years old and I I don't know
if you know there's been a lot of
flooding in Houston oh yeah and I mean
yes last week I got swept away in a
flood when my car and so my car is now
totaled and I didn't it's really old it
was really old and I didn't have full
coverage on it and now I'm without a
vehicle um you know like no I mean I'm
borrowing my dad's van but he needs it
I'm the oldest of eight kids and I work
like full-time but I'm also in ministry
and so I mean a lot of people are
telling me I was just gonna no you can
afford it but I have like one off debt
on my life so and I'm debt free right
now I'm guessing you don't have any
money right hand zero
I mean maybe by the end of the week I'll
have like 200 but right now I don't have
anything what do you what do you make it
your job um like a week or a year either
I mean roughly around 300 a week
sometimes a little less I own my own
business and I'm a retail manager you
own your own business and you're a
retail manager yeah I do both I do house
cleaning Oh both I see okay okay and
you're making a lot more cleaning houses
than you are as a retail manager yes
which is that's what takes up most of my
time I mean I just feel very telling
like on the side okay but you're not
even got 40 hours worth of work cleaning
houses yet do you
you've been my dad we've been making a
lot I mean I probably could I mean I I
mean right now with cleaning that's
where the bulk of my income
from I mean I work 40 hours a week
between both the job right
are you living at home with your parents
yes and I pay them once and stuff so
like it's a house on their property well
it's a difficult mess you're in and I'm
sorry you're facing this what I would be
forced to do would be to see if there's
a way you can continue for like a month
you know working with borrowed cars and
bar and friends helping you in different
things and scratch up scratch up a
thousand dollars to get you a beater
okay yeah that's kind of what I thought
yeah and if you don't know what you're
and you do get coverage on it this time
because you can't obviously you can't
afford to lose a car the so what I what
you're looking for if you don't know and
maybe your dad's already told you this
but when you're buying a beater $1,000
or $2,000 car I call them garage sale
cars because actually a car that is for
sale at a garage sale is a good place to
find one actually and and what you're
looking for is something that is ugly
but that is very mechanically sound yeah
and I'm fine with ugly no it's fine I
mean I was driving a 1992 the example I
will shoot the example always uses I had
a guy working on our team here he still
works aren't team but years ago he was
getting out of debt
and I asked him to run me up to the shop
to pick up my car and I went out to get
in his car and he's like all embarrassed
and he goes you got a ride in big red
and I'm like what's big red there's a
1994 Granada
land yacht you know and big red really
wasn't ready more big red was more pink
because it was faded and I got in and
the dashboard was all split you know
from the Sun and the old vinyl seats
weren't much and he goes I got this car
for 500 bucks from my great-aunt who
never drove it obviously but isn't
listen to this it was a 1990 Ford and
20,000 actual miles on it it already
ever been driven so the mechanics were
all like brand-new the cosmetics were
all horrible and that's what you're
looking for is a big red because all you
want is transportation right now you're
not trying you're not trying to make a
statement and so if you could find big
red for 500 bucks that's who you're that
you know a thousand bucks or whatever
that's what you're looking for and you
kind of gotta just patch work together
and catch it catch a ride with somebody
and that kind of thing until then and
the people that you clean houses for
mm-hmm any of them wealthy people yeah
okay ask them if they tell them what
your situation is not to cry not to cry
river or wine but ask them if they know
of someone and what's your client that
you've had the longest how long have you
been cleaning houses I mean five years
what's your one you have the longest
probably five years okay if you if you
talked to them and told them your
situation would they advance you a few
more well they did there were a couple
clients because I told them I wasn't
even sure if I can make it to my job
this week and just so I could get things
settled but they did offer that and I
wasn't sure if that was wise because
then I'm not sure how then I can pay for
their you got to work at off their
advance that's what I'm saying is like
so if they advance me the paycheck how
am I gonna pay for gas that week if I'm
like buying something else
it's not everybody enhancing your
paycheck it's just that just a couple of
them and that gets you enough to get you
into a little bit of a car and get you
back get you back from walking again and
gives your daddy's van back and then you
get the gas in the car and then what I
want you to do is I want you to really
get in the house cleaning business
completely like like I want you worked
at 40 hours a week and I want you making
20 bucks an hour and that's not a lot
more than that my car do what I make 20
250 an hour no you're not working enough
houses then because the numbers you gave
me are twenty one clients all of your
all of your happy clients no people here
ask them
say I need to add some clients who can I
had I got to get my hours up I gotta get
more hours up can I get more hours from
you or do you have a friend next door
that can use me or a friend that you you
know do stuff at the YMCA with or
whatever I just asked every one of your
clients for referrals because if you've
been cleaning somebody's house for five
years and they're still using you you're
doing a good job because they were they
would have fired your butt otherwise you
know and so the lady that cleans our
home a couple days a week comes and
helps Sharon and believe me just sharing
yakin to her buddies has got this
woman's whole calendar full you know
because she found somebody she could
count on that's what it amounts to and
you're somebody that can be counted on
and that's going to expand your deal
because that's a whole that's if you can
work forty hours at 20 bucks that's
double what you're tell me you're making
at least double and so that tells me
you're only doing about 20 hours worth
of cleaning right now roughly if you're
if your rate is at that so good luck
with this you're going to turn it around
you're going to fight through it and I
suppose you're somebody who will never
be without car insurance again I've
learned a lot of lessons that way too
I'm so sorry you're going through this
Brittany thanks for calling in hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you